continuing coverage of the IG report out
today well despite a number of explosive
revelations some lawmakers are still
suggesting that parts may have been
redacted joining me now to give us
exclusive reaction is House Intel chair
Devin Nunez congressman this is what
we've all been waiting for on this
matter on the Hillary email matter your
initial reaction the first thing I can
think of is is there was information
that we got today at 11 o'clock 12
o'clock that actually chairman Gowdy had
to call and tell me what it was text
messages that we had been asking for
since late last year now these are text
messages that clearly were pertinent to
our investigation into FISA abuse and
the Russian investigation whether or not
there was collusion these are emails or
text messages that somebody held from us
so every day that goes by there is a new
example of obstruction of a
congressional investigation so I want to
read to you an exchange between Lisa
Paige and Peter struck the star-crossed
lovers she basically said you know she
was you know we're worried he's Donald
Trump's not gonna let it get elected
right right and he answers it basically
don't worry we'll stop it no no no we'll
stop it right he was the lead
investigator on the Clinton email case
he's the lead investigator that starts
off the the counterintelligence
investigation using our intelligence
agencies to go after and target the
Trump campaign this is the guy who leads
that off but worse than all that worse
than all that I just want to repeat what
I said in the opening why wasn't that
given to Congress why did I find out
about that today at noon I mean this is
a classic case of obstruction but then
the question is who's gonna go
investigate these guys I mean you know
we're gonna come out we're gonna be very
transparent with the American people
we're altima to get all the documents
that we want and ultimately this is all
going to spill out and then people are
going to ask well what are you gonna do
who's gonna
who's gonna get busted who's gonna go to
jail so lisa pages text was released
before but the struck don't worry we'll
stop it no no we'll stop it that came
today and why is the how could that have
possibly been redacted and that's the
problem they keep blacking things out
across the board not giving us documents
that at the end of the day always end up
being very pertinent to our
investigation the IG wrote the following
and one part of the report under these
circumstances we did not have confidence
that strux decision to prioritize the
Russia investigation over the following
up on the mid-year related investigative
lead discovered on the weiner laptop was
free from bias so the IG cannot
confidently state that that decision was
not free from bias but they're all
dining out on the fact on the left well
there was no political bias on the part
of Comey that was found so they're
trying to really downplay it yeah and
let me tell you what we know about that
at the time so we actually had I've
never actually said this before because
we had whistleblowers but we couldn't
really use the information but now that
it's in the IG report we can we had
whistleblowers that came to us in late
September of 2016 who talked to us about
this laptop sitting up in New York that
had additional emails on it I mean the
house intelligence video we had that but
we couldn't do anything with it when was
that again in 2016 what would you know
when exactly I think it was late
September
okay so ultimately they didn't move on
this until so late October good
FBI agents brought this to our attention
what could we do with it well there's
another exchange I want to bring dear
attentions does he know why I say that
because it was all classified and this
is the game that Comey and company have
been playing as they hide behind this
well they all thought Hillary was gonna
win and rocking the boat was tough he
made a decision to go after that laptop
cuz they he thought okay someone finds
out about they're gonna think the whole
election was illegitimate and then they
quickly dispensed with nothing here to
worry but you know what that's true but
also was true is
I think the same people in charge today
still believe they can run the clock out
and they're trying to run the clock out
for the rest of this Congress so we
can't finish our investigations are
there still people in the FBI today who
believe they operate by a different set
of rules at the top at the top I think
that is still true and we we heard some
great words today from Christopher Rea
the new director but I will tell you
it's a little bit frustrating because
we've had these very conversations with
him many months ago where we said look
you're not responsible for any of the
any of this you need to clean this up
and we'll support you in cleaning this
up but yet here it is today we get this
text message at noon today one that's
absolutely pertinent to our
investigation maybe they have a good
excuse for it but the problem with it is
if they didn't give it to us it's a
problem but if they didn't know about
it's even bigger problem because who was
obstructing the investigation there's
some other things we got to get to it's
another exchange FBI attorney sent
number two they don't identify who this
is and I think it's important to know
who this is for some reason we can't get
the person's name FBI attorney number to
send an instant message to FBI attorney
number one commenting on the amount of
money the subject of an FBI
investigation had been paid while
working on the Trump campaign someone
they were looking at something obvious
they get paid FBI attorney one says is
it making you rethink your commitment to
the Trump administration FBI attorney
number two says hell no viva la
resistance yeah that's awful
resistance to Trump winning is
apparently I mean for all we know still
working at the FBI and blowing this off
on other networks saying this isn't
important well now there's five I think
there's five now yeaji report I think
that I could get through it all but
there's five people who've been kicked
off the campaign right so if there's
five people have been kicked off the
campaign I mean off the Moller team how
is it possible if you look at the rest
of the people that are there I mean they
were all Clinton donors so you know I
don't know how this is this is going to
end up
Fairleigh I don't know where this is
should we learn the names of these these
attorneys who are part of the resistance
I don't know why unless they're an
undercover agent it should not be
classified name no unless they're
working undercover then it should not be
class we also have the type of stuff
that always happens I mean so now I know
how you feel because I feel like it's
happening to the whole country now so
there was another issue involving the
employees FBI employees at every level
of the organization this is from the
report when with no official reason to
be in contact with the media who were
nevertheless in frequent contact with
reporters the large number of FBI
employees who were in contact with
journalists during this time period
impacted our ability to identify the
sources of leaks
we also found that of course they were
giving they were giving getting benefits
from journalists getting perks
they've been leaking like crazy and but
the problem with it is is that IG report
discovered that that this happened a
couple years ago but don't forget the
leak that just occurred last week where
at midnight the Department of Justice
sends out this that that Devon newness
and Paul Ryan had a chance to read
documents and they didn't read them I
mean remember that that was a leak in
the middle of the night a midnight kind
of press release so that we would wake
up in the morning have to answer all
this new narrative that they're creating
that Republicans asked for documents and
don't read them I mean this is what
we're dealing with so it's not as if the
leaks have actually stopped now they're
just doing it it's the FBI people that
were leaking now it's just like at the
top level of Department of Justice is
leaking there was a few people in the
media today more than a few downplaying
all of this I want to play for you a
little short montage let's watch I
expected a sledgehammer we just got the
same kind of hammer you used to nail in
a painting on the wall I don't I didn't
I didn't I would surprise it how mild it
was if you look at this assault on the
FBI that has taken place over the last
year and a half that has been the you
know the clarion call of some of the
opposition saying that you know these
are crooks they're corrupt they tried to
throw an election this report does not
say that
congressman well if you look at the one
gentleman on there I mean that's a guy
that's what a commis buddies he was
working at the FBI I mean look this is a
lot of these agents there are a lot of
the other networks have just hired all
these former FBI and DOJ and Clinton
people and Obama people and that's just
what this is Josh Campbell old buddy of
Comey so nothing there to say this is
all this is all good when you still have
a lot more to get to with the with the
Russia investigation and and you'll
stupic we're almost there
we're almost there but you know there's
a reason why they've been hiding these
documents for two months and this really
very similar to what we found in the IG
report thank you so much appreciate you
coming in tonight any time thank you